عوا بالتحليل مع ضيفنا من رام الله الخبير
والمحلل العسكري اللواء واصف عريقات اهلا
بك لواء عريقات ونحن نشاهد هذا الفيديو
لكتائب القسام ما البارز في اداء المقاومه
ميدانيا ونحن نقترب من مرور شهر ونصف منذ
بدايه هذهه
الحرب يعني ابرز ما فيها
حقيقه هو استهداف الدبابات
واستهداف حاملات الجند ناقلات الجند
المدرعه في حاله التحر في حاله الحركه
وهذه ليعلم المشاهد بانها من اصعب الاهداف
التي تواجه الرماء لانها تحتاج الى معرفه
سرعه الدبابه والاليه وتحتاج الى التوفيق
بين سرعه الدبابه والاليه وسرعه المقذوف
سواء كان ار بي جي او اي مقذوف اخر اذا
كان هناك اذا لم تكن هناك حسابات
دقيقه فلا يتم الاصابه لاحظنا ان كل
الاهداف التي اطلقت على الناقلات وعلى
الدبابات المتحركه اصيبت وهذا ان دل على
شيء يدل على مهارات ميدانيه وقتاليه عاليه
جدا عند المقاومين الفلسطينيين وخاصه ان
الاهداف المتحركه ويعرفها
العسكريون الاهداف المتحركه هي اصعب
الاهداف سواء كانت بالمدفعيه المباشره او
بالمدفعيه الغير مباشره واحتمال الخطا
فيها كبير ولكن في حاله المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين لاحظنا ان النجاح 100% وكل
الاهداف المتحركه اصيبت
وبدقه وهذا ايضا يقودني للحديث بان هذه
الاهداف ايضا تحتاج الى فرق
وخلايا تنسق وتتعاون مع بعضها البعض لانها
تريد لانها تحتاج الى رصد رصد لهذه
الاليات
ودبابات
واتجاهاتها
وسرعتها وهي بحاجه الى معلومات يعني هي
ليست معركه عسكريه ميدانيه فقط هي ايضا
معركه عقول وادم وانا اعتقد انه
الفلسطيني المقاتل الفلسطيني يبرع في هذا
وينتصر ويتفوق على الجندي الاسرائيلي
وربما هذه احد عوامل ادخال الرعب في قلوب
الجنود الاسرائيليين حينما يشاهدون هذه
الكفاءات القتاليه والمهارات الميدانيه
العاليه وكل العسكريين يعرفون ان هذه
المهارات هي يعني احد اسباب الانتصار
الفلسطيني واحد اسباب الفشل الاسرائيلي
واحد اسباب حجم الخسائر حينما تتحدث
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عن 400 اليه او 450
دبابه واليه تم اعطا بها واصابتها انا
اعتقد هذه الفيديوهات تؤكد بالدليل القاطع
بان مهارات مهارات الميدان وقدرات
المقاومين الفلسطينيين ربما تشي بان
الارقام ربما اكثر من ذلك بكثير لان نسبه
النجاح حقيقه 100% ستبقى معي لواء واصف
عريقات ننوه الى العاجل على شاشتنا نقلا
عن حزب الله الذي يقول انهم استهدفوا قوه
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي في موقع المطله
وحققوا اصابات مباشره كذلك سنشاهد هذه
الصور التي وردتنا من غرب مدينه غزه تسمع
فيها اصوات
اشتباكات وتصاعد للدخان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
st
نعود اليك لواء واصف عريقات كنت تتحدث عن
المهارات القتاليه لدى المقاومه عسكريا
بهذه المعطيات وهذه المقومات الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تصل فصائل المقاومه في مواجهتها
لجيش
الاحتلال يعني بالتاكيد واضح ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وحجم الاشتباكات الموجود الان
يؤكد بانها قد اعدت نفسها لمرحله طويله
بدليل ان هناك هناك يعني تناوب هناك تعاون
هناك اقتصاد في استخدام السلاح والذخيره
السلاح والذخيره يستخدم فقط عند حاجته
وعند وعند الاهداف الضروريه وهذا وهذا يدل
على يعني حكمه
وقدرات ومهارات عند المقاومين الفلسطينيين
ونيه وعزم على على خوض معركه طويله الامد
وخاصه ان يعني نعلم ان قطاع غزه محاصر
محاصر برا وبحرا وجوا وامكانيه تزويد
الذخائر فيه صعبه ولكن ما يجري على ارض
الواقع وتقديري وحجم الاشتباكات التي
نشاهدها ونسمعها من خلال الفيديوهات ومن
خلال المراسلين على الارض تؤكد اي على
سلامه على سلامه امكانيات وموجود الاسلحه
والذخائر عند المقاومين الفلسطينيين ين
وخاصه حينما نشاهد بان الاشتباكات موجوده
على كامل المساحه التي تمددت وتوغلت اليها
الدبابات والاليات والجنود الاسرائيليين
وهذا وهذا يشي بان يعني الرهان الاسرائيلي
على نفاذ المعدات القتاليه والذخائر عند
المقاومين الفلسطينيين اعتقد انه ليس في
محله وان هناك امكانيه لحرب طويله من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه و وهذا يشي بان
المخزون الاحتياطي عند المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زال سليما وما زال قادرا
على مواصله القتال لفتره طويله وفي اخر
الاخبار كما نقرا على شاشتنا لواء واصف
عريقات نقلا عن القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه فان 20 جنديا قتلوا في معارك
الشجاعيه خلال الاسبوع الاخير اذا يخسر
الجيش الاسرائيلي المزيد من الجنود
والضباط في صفوفه اي صوره بات يبد عليها
هذا الجيش لواء عرقات هو يخسر هو يخسر من
المقاومين الفلسطينيين صحيح ويخسر من ذاته
يعني ايضا هناك 20 جندي وضابط قتلوا
بنيران صديقه وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل على
حاله الارباك وحاله الضعف و والرعب في في
قلوب الاسرائيليين بحيث انهم يقتلون بعضهم
البعض اما القتلى من المقاومه الفلسطينيه
اعتقد ان هذه يعني شجاعه وبساله وبطوله من
المقاومين الفلسطينيين لانه المعركه الان
هي ليست معركه ميزان قوى صحيح الجندي
الاسرائيلي لديه سلاح فتاك ولديه امكانيات
قتاليه حديثه والكترونيه وكل وسائل
الرقابه ولكن الجندي لا يقاتل بسلاحه
الجندي يقاتل بمعنويات وروحه القتاليه هذه
المعنويات مفقوده عند الجنود الاسرائيليين
وموجوده عند المقاومين الفلسطينيين شكراك
اللواء واصف عرقا الخبير والمحلل العسكري
كنت معنا من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك